where's senpai okay I'm gonna go on my
way now
bye senpai a lonely day at school the
cooking club is the first way to win the
hearts of all your friends and they are
your friends no matter how much they
scream they're not I've got a plate of
octopi they're so cute
look at you look at all of you Oh senpai
don't you one my lovely sausages stand
by
it's gonna hurt my feelings our margins
aren't great if you don't take my food
and put it inside you thank you who are
you
what the hell all right you know what
who do you think you are [ __ ] I'll
smack down with you guys with your
stupid wooden sticks whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa move over move over will show
up alone for a moment
Oh what you didn't ask why did he do
that I was trying to do something epic
right there why did you do that this
means I can win a fight with those
douchebags outside the school I'm gonna
show them what for for not accepting my
spicy sausage not eating the hot dogs
that's what I wanted to say Oh
oh my god yeah sure give it to me
I'm going off to the other world oh I'll
kill people for fun oh my god oh this is
amazing
hi hi [ __ ] Oh God Hey look at me it's a
puppet show ha ha ha ha okay
repeat after me I love senpai yes I do
hate for me not for you
I love senpai yes I do hate for me not
for you I lost